Where can you go to find all the best horror
movies you've never heard of?
One word: Netflix.
The streaming service is packed with zombies
and vampires and hauntings that have flown
under the radar too long.
Here are the most underrated, scream-worthy,
stream-able films currently available on Netflix.
​Midnight Meat Train
Before he gave his voice to a bionically-enhanced
space raccoon, Bradley Cooper was the star
of this incredibly creepy, bizarrely overlooked
New York City horror story.
Midnight Meat Train tells the story of Leon,
a photographer who accidentally uncovers the
existence of a murderous butcher who's using
the New York City subway as his own personal
slaughterhouse.
Needless to say, things get gory — and the
film goes for broke in its final scene with
a seriously twisted surprise ending.
Sadly, a delayed and limited theatrical release
kept Midnight Meat Train from getting the
attention it deserved, especially considering
Cooper's star power and the movie's production
values—but that just makes it one of Netflix's
most hidden gems.
​Train to Busan
The only thing scarier than a roving pack
of zombies is being trapped with them in a
claustrophobic train that's flying through
the Korean countryside at a hundred miles
an hour.
Enter Train to Busan, a fabulous under-the-radar
horror film that milks its unique setting
for all it's worth.
The titular train is barreling through a world
overrun by the undead, bound for a southern
resort city that's rumored to be the last
safe stronghold for humanity.
Train to Busan was a hit at the Cannes Film
Festival in 2016 and broke box office records
in Korea, but it was almost completely overlooked
by American audiences and critics; fortunately,
it's ripe for discovery as a new addition
to Netflix's horror library.
The Pact
Despite a promising release at Sundance in
2012, The Pact never found the audience it
deserved during its original, limited theatrical
run—but this smart, spooky horror flick
is a perfect pick for streaming.
Starring Caity Lotz—who you might know as
Arrow's original ass-kicking Canary—The
Pact tells the story of a young woman with
a troubled past whose mother has died and
whose sister has gone missing…and whose
house may or may not have a few haunted skeletons
hanging around in its closets.
Director Nicholas McCarthy wrings every last
iota of suspense from his miniscule budget,
and Lotz's performance anchors what is ultimately
a quiet but intensely creepy film.
We Are Still Here
This debut film from director Ted Geoghegan
is a modern-day throwback to classic horror.
It tells the story of a couple mourning the
death of their son who move to the country
in search of a fresh start—only to find
themselves haunted by an unspeakable evil.
We Are Still Here premiered at South by Southwest
in 2015 and was considered by many critics
to be one of the best horror films of the
year, with an inventive plot and just the
right amount of artfully-executed gore.
Since then, though, it's been tragically overlooked.
​V/H/S/2
The original horror-anthology film V/H/S has
gotten a decent amount of attention for its
inventive, bite-size tales of terror—because
why take two hours for a slow-burn frightfest
when you can pack multiple horror stories
into the same amount of time?
V/H/S was successful enough to spawn a sequel,
which sticks to the original format but offers
up an entirely fresh crop of scares.
Like its predecessor, V/H/S/2 includes something
for everyone, from zombies to aliens to haunted
body parts.
Stake Land
This underrated apocalypse film tells the
story of an orphaned teenage boy named Martin
living in a world where vampires have overrun
every human stronghold.
With the help of a mysterious vampire-hunter
known only as Mister, Martin makes his way
across America in search of a safe haven,
dodging killers both human and supernatural.
Making the most of a tiny budget, Stake Land
is a best-of-both-worlds mashup between the
apocalyptic horrors of The Walking Dead and
the action of Blade: a smart and compelling
survival drama full of interesting characters,
thoughtful social commentary, and, of course,
bloodsucking monsters.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!